my gradient of cloud can be intimidating
with a ton of things to worry about how
can you build a solid foundation for a
seamless migration well keep watching to
find out welcome to cloud migration 101
where we share migration tips and tricks
when planning your migration to Google
cloud you need to understand some
concepts related to cloud architecture a
poorly planned foundation can cause your
business to face delays confusion
downtime and can't put the success of
your cloud migration at risk for today's
episode I have brought a friend from
solutions architect team who will walk
us through building our cloud
foundations grasp as much as you can and
I'll see you on the other side hi I'm
Travis when migrating from an
on-premises environment or Colo managed
data center to the cloud there are many
things to consider from the IT
engineering and business perspectives
today let's cover the topics that an IT
manager needs to think about when
migrating to Google cloud there are a
few questions you want to ask yourself
first how do your existing business and
organizational structures map to Google
cloud second who from your team will
control administer and audit access to
Google cloud resources third what are
best practices for managing multiple
teams working simultaneously on multiple
Google cloud projects let's start with
the first question how do you model your
existing business and organizational
structures in Google cloud you'll want
to map your existing lines of reporting
and communication to your resource
hierarchy the resource hierarchy
provides structure to your cloud
environment determines the way you are
billed and establishes a security model
for granting roles in permissions it's
like the skeleton for all your cloud
resources for example a compute engine
VM is a resource which falls within a
project and folder and all of these are
contained within an organization now how
do you control access to cloud resources
once the resource hierarchy is in place
you can apply security permissions at
each of these levels these permissions
are then inherited by any child objects
in the
Archy for example if you get full admin
privileges on Department wise folder you
will have full admin privileges on all
of the projects and resources below it
these hierarchies can be as complex or
as simple as your organization requires
a member is who or what you want to give
permission to a role is a collection of
specific permissions to determine what
operations can be performed on a
resource and a policy binds one or more
members to a particular role once you
have a policy you'll be able to clearly
define who can do what on what resources
as a simple equation members plus roles
equals policy let's take a specific
example an enterprise wants to create a
policy for controlling access to all of
their virtual machines they might use
instance admin and App Engine admin
roles then they can create a Google
Group for the ops team that will manage
the instances and the policy would link
the members and the roles together they
could then create a read-only policy
including log viewer and instance viewer
roles for their support team members and
perhaps a policy with the pub/sub
publisher role for the service account
of one of their micro services that
would be three separate policies that's
the relationship between I am and the
resources projects and folders now once
you have the resources in Google Cloud
the question comes how do your teams
actually interact with them there are
four ways to interact with Google cloud
services and your iam permissions will
control what you can do with all of them
first we have the cloud console the
graphical user interface that lets you
interact with Google cloud within your
browser second we have the cloud api's
that provide programmatic interfaces for
interacting with Google cloud from your
application code third the Cloud SDK
which is a developer friendly software
library that enables your applications
to interact with cloud api's and lastly
we have the G cloud command line tool
that lets you make calls to the cloud
API
directly from your command line that was
great Travis thank you thanks you take
it from here I got it
well today we learned about resource
hierarchies access control permissions
using I am and the floor methods of
interacting with Google cloud services
one more details check out the entire
guide linked below and stay tuned for
the next episode where we will talk
about building a landing zone and
running your workloads in cloud in the
meantime give us a like and subscribe to
never miss Google cloud migration tips
[Music]